the concept one is the actually the
first and most powerful electric
supercar so the car cost eight hundred
fifty thousand euros and we are running
a limited series only eight units most
of them are already pre-sold only two
are actually left for others so the
company is from Croatia we started in
2009 building car company in Croatia
that was amazing challenge you don't
have car industry in Croatia you know in
Italy you can be you can basically build
a complete car in one street you have
all the suppliers everything you need in
Croatia you don't have industry at all I
would say you know we are more oriented
to tourism so that was quite challenging
so it has 1088 horsepower goes from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour in 2.8 seconds it
has 1,000 and 600 Newton meters of
torque and top speed is about 325
kilometers an hour I always say we are
not just a supercar company supercar is
just a showcase with our technology can
offer so we are basically also a
technology company and we have two
different pillars of our work so one our
supercars and we will continue to
develop new supercars new models on the
market but also what another segment is
developing our technology and selling
our technology to other companies so we
are doing that and we have other
companies approaching us that want to
develop complete electric cars from
scratch or they want to have motors or
they want us to develop batteries for
them and we do also those kind of stuff